ads on youtube are super annoying it
seems like every year the ads just get
longer and longer and youtube allows
creators to stuff in more and more ads
into their videos given the massive size
of youtube and alphabet you would think
that youtube could place greater
emphasis on the user experience as
opposed to the financial aspect but this
is actually not the case
in fact youtube has burnt money for the
majority of their existence so here's
youtube's money problem and why they
struggle to break even even with all
those pesky ads
starting off youtube is extremely
lenient when it comes to who can upload
onto their site the only requirements
are really just having an internet
connection and a youtube account this is
honestly what makes youtube so awesome
there's basically no entry cost and
anyone can give it a shot
however from a business perspective this
gets kind of messy
at the end of 2020 socialblade estimated
that there were a total of 38 million
youtube channels with at least 5
subscribers
something to keep in mind is that
socialblade only tracks channels that
have been searched for on their website
so the real number is even higher than
that
approximately 20 million of these
channels have less than 100 subscribers
and 12 million channels have between 100
and 1 000 subscribers given that you
need a minimum of 1 000 subscribers to
get monetized around 32 million of the
38 million channels on youtube are not
monetized on top of this in 2016 a
german researcher found that the top 3
percent of channels got 85 of the views
while the bottom 97 percent only got 15
of the views i don't think this
statistic has really changed much since
then which means that youtube has to run
their entire ecosystem off of just a
very small percentage of their content
now the top three percent of channels
likely post much more frequently than
the other 97
so their content likely occupies more
than three percent of youtube's overall
content but i think you get the point
the first cost that comes along with
hosting so much content is of course
storage
every single minute 500 hours of content
was being uploaded to youtube as of may
if youtube actually kept the content in
the same form it was uploaded the data
requirements would be ludicrous but
youtube has perfected their data
compression algorithms and this helps
youtube substantially reduce their data
needs let's look at a video from graham
stefan for instance his videos generally
consist of him talking with some images
and text here and there
i doubt that the average video uploaded
to youtube has the same production
quality as grim whether that be his
lighting or his aesthetic backgrounds
however i do think that the average
video on youtube uses the same style as
gram so we'll use him as the benchmark
one of his most recent videos is a 16
minute 1080p video such videos generally
boast a size of 100 megabytes per minute
of video so this video should be about
1.6 gigabytes when exported however if
we try to download it from youtube we'll
see that the size is only 150.6
megabytes for 1080p and 55.9 megabytes
for 720p nowadays basically every single
smartphone is capable of recording at
least 720p and oftentimes 4k
so i'm going to assume that the average
video uploaded to youtube is somewhere
between 720p and 1080p to keep it simple
we'll say that 15 minutes of video
consumes about 100 megabytes of space
and now comes the hard part which is
estimating how much total storage
youtube is consuming to estimate this
we'll use some logistic regression along
with a bit of calculus over the years we
have a bunch of data points regarding
how much content was being uploaded to
youtube
for example when youtube was launched 0
hours of content was being uploaded
every minute eight years in 100 hours of
content was being uploaded every minute
14 years in 500 hours of content was
being uploaded every minute and so on
and so forth if we graph this logistic
regression curve this is what we get
as you can see the graph starts off slow
but then it rises exponentially before
tapering off this regression actually
makes 506 hours uploaded per minute the
ceiling in reality the taper is likely
nowhere near as aggressive so if
anything we're underestimating the total
content on youtube if we take the
integral between year 0 and year 16 we
get 3 444 hours this means that if we
add up how much content was uploaded in
one minute in 2005 with how much content
was uploaded in one minute in 2006 with
how much content was uploaded in one
minute in 2007 and so on and so forth we
get 3444 hours
if we convert that to an annual basis we
get a total of 1.8 billion hours of
content being uploaded to youtube in
most cases once a video is uploaded onto
youtube it's never deleted
so we'll assume that 90 of the content
uploaded onto youtube is still here
which gives us 1.62 billion hours of
content but that's not it as we also
have to account for redundancy youtube
can't just save every single uploaded
video once as this would make them
vulnerable for losing the video if
something were to happen to the server
that the video is stored on and i'm sure
google does not want to end up like
myspace who lost 12 years worth of music
uploads now google has had a handful of
instances where they lost data in 2015
for instance a lightning strike wiped
out power at a belgium cloud storage
facility google ended up losing 0.0001
of the data stored in the facility
however no customers lost any data
permanently because the data was
replicated across multiple servers so i
feel pretty confident in saying that
every single video uploaded on youtube
has at least one redundant copy
meanwhile the most popular content
likely has dozens of copies around the
world to make streaming to viewers as
seamless as possible to keep things
simple we'll say that the three person
of content that drives most of the views
to youtube are saved 10 times while the
other 97 of content is only saved two
times this translates to a total of 3.62
billion hours of content or 1.45
trillion megabytes of data that's the
same as 1.45 exabytes of data
according to wasabi the five-year cost
of storing one petabyte of data is 1.97
million dollars this includes everything
from the hardware the annual maintenance
and the software to the electricity
costs the cooling costs and the payroll
youtube obviously has outstanding
economies of skill working for them so
we'll say that their costs are only half
of that at 1 million per petabyte for 5
years or 200k per year
that comes out to 290 million dollars or
about 300 million dollars per year in
terms of storage costs moving on we have
the biggest cost for youtube by far
which is bandwidth
in 2017 the vp of engineering at youtube
revealed that youtube hit 1 billion
hours of watch time per day in 2016.
it's been five years since then and the
popularity of youtube hasn't really
slowed down especially with the pandemic
i bet people were watching three blind
hours of youtube per day even before the
pandemic started but we'll estimate with
one billion first to produce a low ball
estimate streaming at just 480p for an
hour uses up 562.5 megabytes of data
720p is 1.86 gigabytes per hour
1080p is 3.04 gigabytes per hour and 4k
is a whopping 15.98 gigabytes per hour
if you've ever streamed over cellular
data i'm sure you're well aware of this
again if we assume that the average
viewer is watching at 720 or 1080p we
get about 2.5 gigabytes per hour of
streaming factor in 1 billion hours of
streaming per day and we get 2.5 billion
gigabytes per day
that's the same as 20 trillion megabits
per day
if we translate that to a per second
basis we get 231 million megabits per
second according to ace data centers
they charge three dollars and fifty
cents per megabit per second per month
if you're using one thousand megabits
per second
youtube is using way more than that so
we'll assume that it only costs youtube
one dollar per megabit per second per
month
that comes out to 231 million dollars
per month or 2.77 billion dollars per
year
if we used a more realistic estimate of
3 billion hours per day this number
jumps to 693 million per month or a
whopping 8.3 billion dollars per year
add the 300 million cost of storage and
we get 8.6 billion dollars per year
the last major cost we have to account
for is payroll as of april 2018 fortune
reported that youtube had a total of
1100 employees
the median salary itself at google was
246 000 per year as of 2019
for 1100 employees that comes out to 270
million dollars which raises youtube's
total operating cost to 8.87 billion
dollars
on top of this youtube also has a bunch
of miscellaneous expenses such as
lawsuits advertising production costs
licensing costs their office building
and so much more
we'll say that all of these
miscellaneous costs add up to a little
over 1 billion dollars per year meaning
that it costs about 10 billion per year
to run youtube but as you might have
noticed all the numbers we used for this
estimate are pre-pandemic numbers the
latest data point we have is may of 2019
so i think 10 billion dollars is more
reflective of how much it costs to run
youtube right before the pandemic
started for the longest time google did
not reveal any of the financial numbers
behind youtube and they still don't
reveal the cost of running youtube or
the final profit however at the
beginning of 2020 google started
revealing the total revenue from youtube
for the first time they revealed that
youtube pulled in a total of 15.15
billion dollars in revenue in 2019 and
11.16 billion revenue in 2018. youtube
introduced back-to-back ads at the end
of 2018
so i suspect that the majority of the
sun increase in revenue was simply due
to showing more ads
considering this if we assume that the
cost of running youtube was
approximately the same for both years at
10 billion dollars we would see that
youtube made one billion dollars in 2018
and if dollars in 2019 before 2018
though youtube was either losing money
or basically breaking even
personally i have a feeling that google
started to report youtube's revenue as
soon as it actually became profitable
this would mean that 2019 was youtube's
first fully profitable year
since then though youtube has become a
cash cow for google thanks to the
pandemic
in 2020 youtube pulled in 20 billion
dollars due to increased viewership and
even if operating expenses ballooned to
15 billion dollars youtube walked away
with at least five billion dollars this
year youtube's prospects are looking
even brighter as youtube is projected to
pull in 29 to 30 billion dollars in
revenue
that probably translates to upwards of
10 billion in profit if we give youtube
the same p e ratio as google youtube
would boast a valuation of 270 billion
dollars given that youtube was burning
hundreds of millions if not billions per
year for the first decade though it's
unclear if google is in the green with
youtube overall
at this point though it's just a matter
of time and it's no question that
youtube was an incredible acquisition
for google did you guys realize that
youtube was losing money for most of its
lifetime comment that down below
also drop a like if you're extremely
grateful that google propped up youtube
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one